[Musique]
le corps du pangolin est recouvert des
cayes
[Musique]
lorsqu'il se sent menacé le pangolin se
met en boule
c est qu à se referme à la façon de
certaines persiennes et vous pouvez voir
à présent ses griffes les griffes des
pattes antérieures celles dont ils
n'usent pas pour marcher mais qui lui
servent à creuser
[Musique]
1 2
sa tête est adapté au genre de chasse
qu'il affectionne et les pointures
affilée ce qui fait qu'il peut
facilement la passe et dans un orifice
une fourmilière où l'on retiré sans
risquer de la voir se coincer
[Musique]
plus agile plus rapide que le premier
que vous avez vu qu'ils étaient un pas
en quoi l'un du kenya celui ci est un
pangolin congolais c'est surtout un
grimpeur
il cède 2,5 à la façon des singes pour
grimper aux arbres
et c'est l'un des rares animaux contre
lequel une termitière attaqué ne peut
rien
les termites peuvent livrer combat aux
fourmis ils peuvent se défendre contre
le pangolin
[Musique]